[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start hey guys and
welcome back to the lay hyalpan show it
is powered by icon
plus capital sponsored by blockfi you
can get up to 250
when you sign up some amazing um
interest rates so i've left um a link
for you in the comments and in the
description and
this episode in particular is actually
um sponsored by compass mining
so they're the company that makes
bitcoin mining accessible for everyone
you just buy your machine pick a hosting
facility and let them
do the work so if you want you can start
mining bitcoin
and you can just head to
compassmining.io so if it wasn't for
them
we wouldn't be able to do these amazing
podcasts okay so today we have a really
interesting guest
joining me is the canadian blogger
influencer
youtuber and podcaster it is
michaela peterson hey how you doing
not too bad thank you so much for having
me on it's good to finally meet you
after
following you on twitter for a while
yeah it's good to meet you too
um i'm a big fan of your father's
you all the work that you guys do um
and yeah i've been really excited to to
have you on so
this is gonna be good when i yeah i'm
excited so
when i was going through all the
different topics that we could talk
about
there is so much um and i wanted to
start off by
talking more really just about your
family
your background because unfortunately
your family has sort of just
come into the limelight i feel like out
of nowhere um you know
your dad went from um you know canadian
professor
lecturer to this suddenly political
figure and you guys just
went into the limelight so i just wanted
to understand you know how that's been
and what your upbringing was like having
a father like
like jordan and jordan peterson sounds
kind of weird to say to you
um but go on it'd be really interesting
to hear okay
well it was pretty out of the blue
um for dad but at least
for like for me and making a podcast i
kind of
you know no i wouldn't say jumped on
that exactly but i took advantage of the
opportunities that presented themselves
so i um i took over dad's kind of social
media i didn't take it over he ran his
youtube
but i was like hey you should be on
instagram you should be on facebook
people will know you and
you know other on other platforms so i
kind of helped him grow that
but it was pretty stressful it's been
pretty stressful the whole time
and there's so many good things that
come of having
as an online following but if it's
super wrapped up in controversy like it
has been with dad
it's been really stressful and i think
for somebody his age as well
it was harder for him like
for me well you you're just more
resilient when you're younger right and
i kind of grew up with the internet and
even though social media was a little
bit late like i didn't have that as a
kid
but it's still easy to wrap my head
around and
the whole situation has been so absurd
for my dad that has been
like much harder for him and stressful
you know worried about losing his job
worried about what would happen like if
you
end up in huge newspapers or huge
magazines
people calling you you know an alt-right
you know
horrible human being it's like what are
people gonna think of me and that amount
of stress
has been very very very damaging to my
family
like so i've been
you know just what i've grown for myself
with a podcast and
online following that's been okay i can
handle that but
the controversy that my dad has
experienced has been
too much i would say it's been a lot so
we live in a world we lit yeah firstly
i'm so sorry to hear you know we live in
a world where
these words are just thrown around
alt-right racist
um you know white supremacists
and how how then as a family are you
able to
deal with those accusations because i
think it's concerning because eventually
these words will lose meaning and lose
value oh for sure i mean you throw
yeah i mean particularly the word racist
is thrown around in so many ways that
don't actually mean racist that
yeah you do lose the word and it's
actually a really important word to have
so that's silly but how like as a family
how are we dealing with it i kind of
think well i don't know like i said
i've i think probably because i grew up
with the internet and kind of
kind of understood the i don't know
just people online and trolls and was
like yeah it doesn't really matter like
if someone prints something about you it
doesn't
really matter it does matter and it does
cause enough stress that people
like it ruins people's lives right
people can be
get taken down by the mob or cancelled
they end up committing suicide like it
can actually get
really really bad um and i think it's
probably harder for older people who
well i don't know i can't even only
blame it on age because obviously it was
more impacting his
direct character than it has been for me
but i think it has something to do with
age and just the absurdity of the whole
situation
yeah i think you know because we're this
age
where millennials we're sort of i know
we haven't necessarily grown up with
this level of social media but
certainly like you said more resilient
um yeah
i think yeah no i i i can appreciate
that and
i mean i couldn't imagine my dad sort of
receiving the same kind of
the same the same how do i put it um
controversy you know i just i couldn't
imagine it it must be tough um
but you know this this new world like
i'd love to hear your opinion on
where you think we're going you know
there are so many things that we're not
allowed to say
anymore and things that we're not
allowed to discuss i mean
it'll be really interesting to talk
about covert and things like that
especially because
just now the news has just come in so
this is really cool to talk to you about
it
that um in the uk they'll be
implementing vaccine passports
for clubs and bars um
so yeah in terms of what you can and
can't say
you know where do you sound on that
i don't know what's gonna happen like
i've been pretty pessimistic about the
whole thing
yeah i i wasn't in canada for like four
months because
i was you know i don't want to live here
it's scary downtown is empty everyone's
walking around
fearful and i'm back now but people are
still fearful things are slowly opening
up
uh i'm i'm sure that they'll i'm not
sure
i'm pr fairly certain that they're going
to implement some sort of vaccine
passport
uh and i don't know
how things are gonna go i mean it's
interesting because we have the social
media and we're able to have jobs online
and everything kind of went remote that
people
i think people will end up moving to
places that they wouldn't have normally
moved to
like i was in belgrade for a while that
was amazing croatia is pretty nice
i don't know what covid laws are going
to be like in those
places and they might be just as strict
i'm not sure but at least they don't
have this kind of
for lack of a better word liberal
undertone that's
freedom of speech so so there's two
problems going on there's the
oh things are going in a bit of a weird
direction with
freedom of speech and you know certain
terms that are being thrown around like
racist white supremacists whatever but
then on top of that we have the
covid restriction problem and so i don't
know i think some people are going to
end up moving i mean you can see what's
happened in the u.s
where people are like well i guess la
isn't the place to be anymore yeah
so that must just continue
the uk is interesting it's interesting
that they implemented that because
from what i know about the number of
people vaccinated is most people who are
going to nightclubs the younger
like generation haven't even had time to
get more than one
well no so so they're not implementing
it until the end of september to give
people time
to force right do it faster yeah yeah
but the thing is my
my thing with it is and i actually just
tweeted about this is that for me it's
so obvious that
it's not a good thing like forcing
someone to put a foreign substance in
their body to me it's just so obviously
not a good thing
yeah well it's not it's not really that
though is it it's not really whether
it's been tested it's kind of just
it's just medical coercion i feel like
people should be free to choose
well yeah i i do too
but i mostly do because well i don't
trust the medical system very much
okay um and i i i just had covet i just
got over
yes i was gonna ask you about that in
moscow yeah so that's the second time
i've had it
and it was it was bad enough
and i put i put a video out because i've
been pretty vocal vocally like against
lockdowns and
suspicious of everything and i put a
video out saying you know
if this specific covid situation doesn't
end for the next number of years like if
this is just a virus that's around
and the vaccine turns out to help and
not have any
serious side effects for young younger
people
i'll probably consider getting it later
as much fun as having covid once a year
is because the last time i had it i was
and i'm pretty healthy
but i still have like this morning i
woke up i have a slight wheeze
i'm covered negative i haven't had hovid
for like weeks now but i still have a
slight wheeze
and i'm i'm pretty healthy so
i don't know yes i'm against the
government forcing
anybody to pretty much do anything
because i don't think anyone can
tell a whole bunch of people what to do
with any sort of
intelligence um so you are and your
vote so you're you're vocally against
lockdowns can you tell me more about
that because for some people
it's so hard just to it's so hard just
to be like
go on go for it yeah go look at you like
getting comfortable
man so i've been vocally against that
since you know
we i was in florida when covet hit and
then i think may
after covet hit i was like okay this
lockdown thing is not going to be a good
idea
and i feel like if you had half a brain
you could figure out why it wasn't going
to be a good idea
that wasn't going to be a good idea
because there are going to be people who
don't have any money
who are going to get very unstable um
every time people lose
jobs there's an increase in the death
rate
suicides go up overdoses when people are
stressed out
and i was like well how is how is the
government going to be able to monitor
all the kind of secondary deaths due to
a lockdown
and compare it to covid and now this the
data is finally coming out after it's
been
i don't know how how long has it how
long have you been has it been like 18
months
well it started it came in march 2017
yeah yeah so it's been a while um
but some of the data some of the data is
coming out and at least
in where did i just shared something i
can't remember if it was from the us
or canada but the even just the number
of overdoses that have increased in the
last
year in young people have killed more
people than kovit has
so that's just one factor that's just
overdoses
and that's young people so we're locking
everything down to save
people who are above 80 without even
asking them if they're okay with it
like hey how about you you don't see
your family for a year and also you make
your grandchildren depressed
and potentially suicidal and you you
don't have a choice
because it's for your own good like
i don't know no you make that you make
such an interesting point because no
you're exactly right because it does
disproportionately affect
young people and a lot of people 80 plus
share that exact opinion
i was talking about this with my
grandfather he's like 93
and um despite the lockdowns we live in
different parts of the country like a
three-hour drive and despite the
lockdowns
i still went to see him he still wanted
me to go see him
of course because he's old yeah
what else are you gonna do i know and i
went to i actually went to go fill his
fridge for him and
i'd posted it so i'm quite um vocal
about what i'm doing and i always go
fill his fridge bless him you know put
some nice
meat in there so he was all sorted for
the winter
and um people were criticizing me
and i thought my grandfather needs to
eat and he's 93. like you need to mind
your own business
and unfortunately nobody's able to mind
their own business nowadays and i feel
like
we're all sort of told yeah say that
again sorry
well i don't know how much social media
has to do with that i don't know if this
would have been happening the same way
if we didn't have social media and we
couldn't see everything
like into everybody's lives it might
have been completely different wow
yeah it heightens it so it heightens all
the fear because things
spread easily right but also people are
actually able to move their jobs
to their home more than they would have
before
so we actually had the ability to work
from home which
you thought would be a good thing but it
turns out it just shut everything down
so it's tricky yeah it's a very strange
world we live in and another
topic i really wanted to discuss with
you um was good old feminism
um and i'd love to know your stance on
it and
the main question i have for you really
is do you think modern day feminism has
a place in today's society
i've been doing a lot of like research
kind of
so i have a daughter she's almost four
and
i've been trying to learn more about
like my own i guess
psychology because i can see some of the
things that i don't like in myself
showing up in her because they you know
kids
so i'll do something that i'm kind of
not aware of
you know maybe get resentful about
something just something like that
and then i she'll kind of display it and
i'll be like oh my god so i
i actually have to fix that so it
doesn't pass on so
wait you have to give me an example i
don't understand you have to give an
example
well okay say i'm upset about something
like say something stressful happens and
i'm upset about it
if i don't actually like healthily
express that emotion
and try and get it out if i'm just like
okay everything's fine i'll just like
hold this in until
later when i'm by myself or something
she gets obviously you can feel that
kind of energy when you're around people
right if you're around someone who's
upset and they're pretending
everything's okay
everybody can feel that but i've been so
that's what i mean once you have kids
you know if you're around other adults
they can all pretend that nothing's
happening but when you have kids
they'll start displaying like emotions
that you're like pent up holding so
when that started happening and i'm like
i've been through
a number of stressful things like
especially in the last couple of years
so she's been around a lot of stress so
i've been trying to figure out how to
helpfully deal with that bring that back
to feminism
i think i think recently
things got a little bit confused because
there are
ways to you know there are certain
things that need to be talked about
the way that we're handling it now and
that modern day feminism is handling it
now
isn't healthy which is too bad because
i think it's the you know feminists
started
on the right foot i think yes to try and
say you know you know women need
these things maybe women are different
people maybe being a mom isn't so bad
like it it started in kind of a a
different universe
and it ended up here where there's you
know toxic masculinity
which even just saying that kind of
thing
is making the problem you're trying to
solve worse
yes so what do i think about it i think
that
people need to be more educated
in like terms like codependency and
i just had this was really interesting
actually do you know the book uh
no more mr nice guy it's by this guy it
sounds
really familiar yeah it's a bestselling
book i'd heard of it too but i just
talked to him on my podcast dr robert
glover and he's one of these
like men's group not therapists for lack
of a better word he's a doctor
but right um we talked a lot about how
you know childhood trauma can manifest
in different ways
as a man when you're older as a woman as
you're when you're older
and having conversations like that
is it's just different than saying hey
men are evil
which doesn't help anybody
so i don't know this like i told you
earlier i'm a little bit pessimistic
about the state
i think lots of people are a little bit
pessimistic i'm pessimistic i'm
pessimistic because i'm unfortunate
but uh like canada i don't know how
canada is gonna turn out
i'm hoping that it'll be able to recover
from this but there's a number of things
that are going wrong
like i said not just covid but also the
i don't know liberal movement i don't
even know what to call it the
call it the liberal movement even though
they're not all for freedom and like
what liberal really means we can
we understand we get it it's been
hijacked like that yeah so that's
happening i don't know if canada's gonna
make it i don't know if
i'm considering moving to the states i'd
love to move to austin
or you know somewhere like that but i
don't know how many wait just
is that difficult as a canadian i have a
not really i think i can get an 01 and i
have a second
visa like if they go there and live
there for six months they're not allowed
to work though
so i i'd have to deal with a visa
which but i think i can get an 0-1 so
fortunately i don't think it would be
that hard but i don't even don't even
know how
how long some of those cities are going
to be okay for
or whether they're going to be like
taken over by
postmodern liberals i don't know like i
don't have words for them
no i understand and like you know just
just back to the
the feminism topic there's so much going
on it that we're not allowed to talk
about which is why i love doing this
podcast because
we can say what we want um within reason
and right now you know we have the
olympics
and we saw there's a trans woman um who
i
believe beats some i think she won right
well she won she won as a weightlifter
so
my thing is it's really simple each to
their own right
but i really feel that modern-day
feminism just isn't pro-women
like for me i can't understand how
that's pro-women
i i completely i completely agree
i do not know how this happened that
didn't happen
it's weird that you put the you put the
right wing conservatives in the group
that are like
more pro-women it just yes it's upside
down right now
it's very it's very strange where are
you right now
are you still in the uk yeah i'm in the
uk
um today is called freedom day um so
it's the day
that our restrictions have lifted um but
i don't plan to stay here like i said
they're bringing in vaccines
freedom day yeah yeah
both sides are uncomfortable with that
why does that make you shiver
oh that's so creepy yeah we'll
go online well why would they name it
freedom rather than
something that has to do with covid like
if
okay if kobit restrictions are being
lifted then
call it something that has to do with
that not like now you're free again
like what yeah i mean so both sides are
uncomfortable with it so let's just say
people that are
pro lock down don't like it because now
it sounds like this is about um
authoritarianism rather than like
uh medicine and health and public health
and things like that so they don't they
think that that's propaganda right
so they're just like no you're
distracted from the narrative this isn't
about authoritarianism this is about
health
but then the people who are against it
yeah and then the people who are against
it
also feel i don't i don't know it's a
creepy day but to be honest it's
something to do with authoritarianism
well yeah because it's like that if
you're trying to get away from that
like storyline i guess it's too i
decided that
i don't know i guess it's probably been
decided i don't actually know the prime
minister uses the term freedom day
um it's a pretty to me it's a great name
i think it's a great name
i because it literally describes what's
happened it literally describes it
no it does it definitely does it's just
if you were in the
this is why i don't trust the government
it's like
if you were trying to weave some sort of
storyline
that was against this right-wing
authoritarian
plot why would you name the day freedom
day how can you mess up that badly
it was probably like an 18 year old
working in an office somewhere and
they're like we need a name you didn't
come up with a name
no what about freedom day yeah okay good
enough whatever no one's going to pay
attention anyway
yeah well you know that's politics for
you and and that's the government for
you but um
no i i do i do want to delve a bit more
into your opinion on feminism these days
um because it isn't pro women and i
don't know
whether um you think we could ever get
to a point where things could sort of
reach a nice equilibrium you use the
time toxic masculinity earlier
um i think it's a stupid time you know
if you're trying to have a conversation
with someone
you can't insult them back you know um
so do you think we'll ever get to that
equilibrium i don't think the trajectory
we're headed on right now is
is heading in any sort of equilibrium
universe
so are we going to get so what do we do
i don't know it's tricky i've been
so i get fed up with how things are
looking here
and then i'll go somewhere like okay
i'll go to eastern europe right it
doesn't have the same problems other
than covet it doesn't have it has
different problems though right so you
go there and you're like oh [ __ ]
you know the north american
infrastructure which is something
everyone here takes for granted
including me
is actually incredibly well set up like
it's amazing that the society functions
this well
and i went to i was in russia for a
while
and a couple of other places but there
are basic things there that are missing
because
north america is really well set up and
people here are forgetting it so
like i said i don't think it's heading
in a good direction but i don't know
where else to go
i don't think that i feel the same
sentiment it doesn't it's fine
it's fine because your sentiment your
sentiment says enough it's completely
fine but you spoke about earlier you
know
making money online and at least that's
something that we can do
um and you know you've got a super
successful podcast
amazing guests so how do you how do you
do that
balance all this stuff going on in your
personal life like we spoke about
earlier
this increasing authoritarian world you
know you're really building something
for yourself
so from like an entrepreneurial
standpoint then you know like how do you
how do you go about that how do you deal
with that well i'm i'm really happy with
how things
have turned out in my work life
like the podcast is unbelievably
successful i still can't believe people
watch it like that really it really
surprises me
uh and people seem to say yes when i ask
them to come on
so and i've learned enough about social
media that
well i've managed to like delegate some
tasks so i'm not doing everything myself
anymore which is also a relief so i've
i'm set up really well work wise
uh i don't know how to balance that
properly with the rest of my life
like i i do end up but you do i don't i
do sometimes i'm doing a podcast doesn't
mean
everything else is well organized the
podcast is well organized
i'm still well that's new certain that's
news to the outside world
yeah yeah what would you say okay fine
so what would you say some of like the
three main things are to building a
successful podcast then
consistency um so
i mean i had a i had a head start
because
people know my dad my dad has a podcast
i already had a social
media following so if you already have a
social media following
then things are going to be easier for
you obviously yeah
but i would say if you don't have a
social media following and you want to
start one it would be consistency
and i know i know some people who've had
podcasts for a long time and they had
like hardly any views
hardly any views for a really long time
and then it
was kind of like a pareto distribution
of viewers
so i would say consistency don't
talk all the time when you have a guest
on like
people are going to get bored of your
podcast really quickly if it's just you
talking all the time
unless maybe you're tim dylan or a
comedian
so that doesn't that's not the same for
everyone but most people aren't very
funny so
don't talk too much especially if you're
not
a popular comedian uh so let's see
consistency don't talk over the ghast
and then i guess the other thing would
it's pretty this is
this is pretty easy but make sure you
post it everywhere
like have a youtube channel have an
instagram channel use
tick talk use twitter like don't don't
think that you're better than one
platform when tick tock came along a lot
of people were like
oh you know tick tock is full of like
dancing
you know half naked women i'm not going
on tick tock but when youtube started it
was all cat videos
so you just don't don't think you're
better than a social media platform and
use all of them because it's better to
put your stuff
up somewhere and not have it watched
than to miss out on one of the big
platforms
so yeah consistency don't talk over the
guest and
use social media properly
yeah take talk is a huge honor totally
right when that first came about people
would i was posting videos on there and
everyone was sort of laughing and
i was like no trust me this is good this
is good i see um
clips from your dad on there all the
time
all the time it's it's so amazing it's
it's honestly brilliant um
intellectual content like yeah is making
its way
on there oh yeah it's not there yeah
so it's it's worth it uh i find it i
find it very interesting and i know it's
this like evil
chinese company but it's so good at like
if i actually spend some time on there
and like
videos i spend some time just to figure
it out and like
videos that i like the algorithm
is amazing it'll amazingly yeah it'll
instantly show me what i like or if i
don't
interact with it enough it'll show me
what it thinks i like
so i've been getting like i'm not that
like if
politically i'm libertarian like through
and through i'm not
super conservative
oh i think you're i think
your camera has frozen hang on let me
see if
it's me that's gone or you that's gone
guys can you tell me if i've
frozen or if michaela has frozen let me
know
in the comments if it's me or michaela
cause
i'm not sure let's have a look
maybe if i i'm good okay so michaela's
frozen all right
let's see if we can get her back
oh wow her power went out okay guys her
power went out
that is crazy yeah her power went out
all right let me see how quickly we can
get her back in
okay
let me see if we can get her back in see
this is honestly live
that's what happens when you go live
let's see if i remove her okay now it's
just me
all right well why would we wait for
mikaela to come back in
yeah she's coming back in okay well why
wait for her to come back in
um i'm gonna give a quick shout out to
my sponsors because guys without my
sponsors we just wouldn't be here
so shout out to blockfy um i left a
little um
i left a link for you guys you can get
amazing interest rates and 250
when you sign up and actually my newest
sponsors
this month um is compass mining so they
are the company
that makes bitcoin mining accessible for
everyone um you can just get a machine
pick a hosting facility and let them do
the work which is pretty cool because if
you think about it
mining bitcoin is so difficult right now
so
compass mining i'm making it super easy
for everyone
let's see how michaela is doing
okay while we wait for michaela guys if
you have any questions
i'm gonna take this opportunity to do an
ama while we wait for michaela so
feel free to leave your questions so
i said trudeau is listening that's
really funny um is that why the power
went out
all right i'm gonna leave this
opportunity
i'm gonna take this opportunity to am i
british or australian
i feel like it's kind of obvious isn't
it i'm british
but you know what's really really funny
as we were talking about
um as we were talking about tick tock
her power went out it's kind of crazy
all right let's see what else if she is
coming in guys i'm going to take this
opportunity to do
a ama so feel free to
leave your feel free to leave your
questions
all right i'm having a look at that okay
all right so michaela has just said that
she can't
her power's not coming back on that is
crazy okay
so guys i guess we won't be able to
continue that's a shame i wanted to ask
her
about bitcoin um i think we were still
gonna go for another
20 minutes um but i will stay on for
another five minutes you guys are
welcome to ask any questions because
obviously i want to
make this a great podcast for everyone
so feel free to throw any questions in
i'm gonna go up now and actually have a
look at some of the comments that came
through
um someone says they always like to
watch that's very nice
let's have a look leia remembers march
bitcoin dip of course i remember the
bitcoin dip in march
um let's have a look what are my
thoughts on xrp i really don't have any
major thoughts on xrp i know everybody
seems to think that i do but i
i really don't um will bitcoin continue
to go down it's impossible to predict
this kind of market
um all you can do is hold i haven't sold
any bitcoin i'm also really vocal about
the fact that i actually
get paid in bitcoin so i was getting
paid when bitcoin was at its all-time
high at 60 000
and i decided not to sell of course i'm
not gonna sell like why would i sell
i'll take a 50
hit so no i'm i'm happy to hold um even
if bitcoin
goes back goes down it will go back up
so i'm not i'm not overly concerned all
right i'm gonna
continue to answer just a few more
questions um
somebody said either michaela froze or
she's the best statue that's funny no
she furries unfortunately
why do you think france is threatening
jail time for not having vaccine
passports but the uk just lifted all
restrictions so actually the uk
has just lifted all restrictions but
that doesn't necessarily mean it's a
good thing
because they actually announced today
that they're gonna be um
implementing vaccine passports for
nightclubs and large events at the end
of september
um so this isn't uh this isn't
necessarily a good thing for me this is
unbelievable it's medical coercion but
i've spoken about that i'm not gonna
continue to go on about it all right i'm
gonna answer one more
question i see some conspiracy theories
in the comments
that's that's good fun i'm gonna answer
one more question we'll look through
your questions now and then
we'll we'll call it a day on today's
podcast
you're welcome for a response more than
welcome okay i'm gonna answer one more
question
okay where am i going in the us
okay so once my book is done um i do
hope to get to the us
that will be so actually i was talking
about this today so my book was set to
launch at the end of july
and um it probably will launch at the
end of july um
but we are delayed a little bit so for
those who don't know i've written a book
about bitcoin it's called undressing
bitcoin
and the goal of this really is to make
bitcoin accessible for everyone i find
that
the it's quite a difficult and complex
and sophisticated topic and i really
wanted to just make it fun like i want
to make it fun lots of flavor
taste excitement and i initially started
writing this
as a guide it was initially a guide that
was the whole goal
and as i started writing i was getting
more and more excited and i was
getting really excited by all the um the
philosophy behind bitcoin you know when
we talk about freedom decentralization
um bitcoin has a humanitarian solution
to all the tragedies that's going on in
this world
um so i ended up turning this guide
into a book but it was heavy and there
was so much in there you know like when
you
love a topic you end up putting so much
into it
um so it was just too much unfortunately
um fortunately my brother and i were
actually in the same country at the same
time
we've both been traveling he's been
traveling but we're in the same country
at the same time
and um i showed him the book and he was
like it's good
but i think it should be a little bit
more like this and so honestly i'm
taking this opportunity to rewrite
quite a lot of things um i've cut down a
lot for example i'll give you full
disclosure full examples
um the first chapter is the first
chapter is the death of
fiat okay and
in that chapter i spoke a lot about the
financial crisis mainly
the 2008 financial crisis mainly because
bitcoin was largely born out of it
and um i spoke too much about it
and i think it's boring so i decided to
delete it
like i've deleted like 15 pages of this
book so far so i decided to delete it
because it's boring
and i want to keep it as concise and as
fun as possible
there are some memes in the book because
memes are good
memes are exciting so there's some means
in the book um
but yeah overall that was the goal and
it did really start off actually as a
guide
that's what happened um and it was a
guide that i was going to sell
by myself um but no i i i just got
really carried away
i couldn't really carry away with
bitcoin as this humanitarian solution
um you know and yeah i'm excited i'm
really really excited so essentially
when that's done
um i will then
go to the states to answer your question
so i do want to go to the states i will
go to the states um
somebody says my my connection is
breaking up i don't think it is i feel
like i have a really good connection
you guys can let me know if it's
breaking up um but yeah i do want to go
to the states but i'm gonna finish
my book first so i actually finished
writing it three weeks ago but like i
said my brother and i are actually going
through it now and just
adding more spice and more flavor to it
um i'm just reading i'm reading all the
comments as you guys are talking to me
that's like talking this is really weird
to multitask i did this the other day
actually
um yeah so once the book is written
which
um should be well once the book is
re-edited it's quite a heavy edit that
we're doing
i will um do an audio version
and um that audio version will be
available so it'll be totally available
on amazon you can buy the kindle version
the paperback oh and then what i'll do
is when i walk when i do go to the
states because
most of you guys are um based in america
so once i do go to the states
i'll probably do a meet-up and a book
launch um
so yeah we can all meet we can i can
sign the books or whatever because i
can't actually send you signed copies
because i'm doing it through amazon
but i'll definitely do a meet-up so i'll
let you guys know when that's happening
um okay i think i think that is all guys
um unfortunately michaela couldn't stay
um
she had a power cut guys never forget
the power cut happened when we were
talking about
tick tock i just i don't think i'll ever
get over that
we were talking about d platforming
freedom of speech tick-tock
china things you can and can't say five
very controversial topics in today's
world
and um her power cut out quite
unbelievable
all right guys well thank you so much um
for tuning in and for your comments
and thank you for hanging out with me
while um michaela left
unfortunately but we'll definitely get
that back up i actually have another
podcast this week
really really exciting so tune in for
that um it's with um
a guy who's based in nigeria so you know
ah
i'm still here i was gonna end this but
just last thing i'll say you know how i
was saying
um how bitcoin is this humanitarian
solution and all that well i'm going to
be speaking with a guy who uses bitcoin
and he's based in nigeria
i'm super excited if you didn't know i
believe
in nigeria don't quote me on this but
i'm more or less right
um there's a limit of a hundred dollars
a day
you're allowed to make for like
international payments
um it's just unbelievable the
restrictions in nigeria um
and what's happening happening with
their central bank um so yeah guys
definitely tune in i think it's on
thursday
um subscribe to my youtube so you don't
miss it you'll get a notification
when um i go live and then that's it all
right guys i'm gonna go now and need to
find
how i need to find the um i have a
little jingle that i play when i leave
so all right i'm going to play it now
alright guys thanks so much i'll speak
to you all soon bye